i scratch and mix music and videos the
art of scratching and mixing just sucked
me in and I just and I forgot about
everything else that that I wanted to do
in life the technology for controlling
video started to happen and oddly enough
the instrument was a turntable when I
saw my head was gonna explode just cuz I
was like wow this is you can actually
see turntablism now the music definitely
has to match the visuals in a certain
way like a office space like there's no
music in that part of the film at all
which is perfectly so it's like an
acapella
Oh
when I first got the software to do it I
was thinking okay they're gonna use the
Star Wars call everyone's gonna scratch
the matrix and everyone's gonna like you
know do the lightsaber fights Wow guys
can we think alike think longer than
five minutes about this simple don't be
with the tip from Battle Royale it's
like Lord of the Flies but with machine
guns and lots blood they take a random
classroom of like seventh graders throw
them on an island put exploding collars
on them time it's that if you know if
they don't kill each other they're gonna
like four or die randomly every night or
I'll use a film like obviously I said
everybody gets her or something from
peanuts that everybody gets infused the
adventure uh youtube live was all the
people who s have have some success on
YouTube not the shoes guy chiz I was at
home cuz I've done live show that's like
what I do mostly but these other people
who made these songs in their bedroom
and you know with their you know a
little webcam it cut it had to be a
little scary for them I got a min and
and not everyone looked super juiced
it's for the kids